hello and welcome to this video duh
factory yeah that's a new opponent I'm
going to test a little bit of the
English rep at one okay it's not the
kind of person who thinks about it well
okay basically what he or setting up is
a king's indian kind of structured you
can play those moves pretty quickly okay
i want to make sure that if five is not
so easily playable for EM okay might be
out for you for and I think I'm ready to
trade this and now go back so that I
have good control over the long diagonal
ok so maybe wants to go at five efore
sometimes as an opportunity him you fall
and if i take with the night f5 i have
no Squared's kind of a funny idea so
maybe cover c3 for the moment you
thought maybe i'm out for see if I check
it not not really i will go p5 him make
it difficult for him to develop the
night okay so maybe just rugae one get
this traded
with the pressure on c6 you cannot move
the night we're interesting to see how
is going to solve this problem yeah the
bishop on g2 is really the old star p is
in many english english opening setups
here we see that yeah blackest having
some issues okay Queen to be six maybe
taking doesn't really do much
okay maybe just this move him still he
cannot move the night and I have queen
85 possibly okay can go before I'm
overlooking things here hmm it was
pretty awful it was very awful actually
yeah that looks wrong as well okay
Queenie for wasn't was a completely
idiotic move I forgot that this light is
is loose
they probably just take one two three I
mean maybe you can make a 97 look I
don't know he wants to play very
ambitious slay okay might work
it might have work
fatigue on d5 he has this immediate d4
thread
that's pretty uncomfortable doesn't
completely unnecessary I mean he was
essentially a rag come on let's not go
down it was essentially busted already
strategically and I let him back into
the game by going Queen 84 okay it's a
very uncomfortable position would be 80
sir it's coming I have to have to put
this back
okay not sure at least is giving me the
square I have not G 5en this position at
the anti will take here i am not quite
sure about all this i am taking too long
ok this is also possible
night h4 can be an idea Wendy for is
hanging but so is g six and a half but
should be four maybe after night h4
let's see how you how he handles this
you
it's not easy if I'm not H for bit it's
a bit annoying and sometimes i also have
d5 okay so how this is the dress night
h4 I don't see how
maybe you can take on the phone now with
the night no
okay time warning
right i hope they don't get night at 52
okay unfortunately i can have to play
them to not fall too far behind in time
even though that very likely wasn't the
best yeah it's a good move it's a good
move I guess now this cannot be right
rhythm about 25 seconds yeah it's strong
its strong
and probably I should have played that
other stuff 95 I know it was probably
good the way up late but I just didn't
continue correctly you can just take
both nights now and win easily I've got
this week group Group B 1 him I don't
know I'm not doing well yeah white
resides I just don't convert the good
positions that I get um yeah okay so
maybe this position is excellent for
white absolutely excellent this this
it's almost busted here because it
cannot move any of its pieces night on
the seven cannot decently move this is
just a mini otic move completely
yachting this for example our look is
heaven not so it's just clearly better
for white because my pieces are just
just stronger and he cannot move any of
his pawns there the thing is this is not
possible and how do you develop your
pieces here I have Queen 83 Queen 85 or
queen 8327 is just terrible okay Queen
84 I didn't see four and now he's he's
in fine shape so we had this no he
played f4 a 94 okay yeah I've 95 but I
wasn't sure about this check check I
mean this is kind of position is that
clear with me I don't think so i guess
all that but ok anyway I decided for
this and I came here yeah and now I mean
isn't that age for something the engine
gives night age
five with the grades with a big
advantage now I didn't consider this
first night h5 what do we add move I now
it goes down evaluation wise to equal
yeah tough i think the engine probably
needs a bit of time here to evaluate it
correctly yeah and here this is the
critical position I couldn't really find
something good and played d5 at the end
which is probably not good oops I'm
sorry it took it I probably have to take
with the bishop him and 92 is very
strong matters losers yeah okay it's
it's it's just the game well he got to
basically outplayed in the opening but
then i played this ridiculous screen 84
and after that the position is fine for
him let's just find him it was kind of
Milky actually thought I might have
something with the engine doesn't really
confirm that so I guess it was a well
played game that I'm also 92 it's very
strong it really ends all kinds of ideas
him for me yeah tough time thanks for
watching